[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to lab Roots the life
of her mind an interview series devoted
to learning how women think about their
research their field and their future
let's get started today we're in
conversation with Dr Gina trojiano
Joseph Levitan professor of vision
science in the biology department at
Brandeis University where she heads the
terrigiano lab
Dr trojiano completed her undergraduate
studies at Reed College and her PhD at
the University of California San Diego
publishing on an array of topics and
Neuroscience since 1997. Dr trojiano has
long focused her research on brain
plasticity
Recent research furthers the
understanding of homeostatic plasticity
mechanisms through studying sleep wake
cycles and the results of her research
include advancements in understanding
how so-called self-tuning mechanisms
relate to brain disorders like epilepsy
and autism
Dr terrigiano's work has been recognized
with fellowships from the MacArthur
Foundation The Genius Grant and Sloan
foundation and awards from the McKnight
Foundation the National Institutes of
Health and the human Frontier Science
Program organization
a member of the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences and National Academy of
Sciences a fellow of the American
Association for the advancement of
Science and the president of the society
for Neuroscience Dr triggiano is a
groundbreaking researcher working at the
Leading Edge of Neuroscience welcome Dr
trojiano and thank you for taking time
to give us a glimpse into the life of
your mind
thanks Mia it's great to be here
okay so fun fact
within 10 years of completing your
undergraduate degree you became a
faculty member at Brandeis that's pretty
extraordinary how did you do it
well first I would say that for my
generation
um this is a little bit less
extraordinary so
post talks were not as long back in in
my day as they have become and you know
part of that is just the overall
increase of sort of competitiveness of
science which is uh you know it's um
papers are more complicated now they
take more approaches and so it tends to
take longer for postdocs to bring
projects to fruition so I sort of zipped
through my postdoc in like four years
which is pretty um pretty unusual
um certainly now but back then it wasn't
quite as unusual
um and then the other thing I would say
that's sort of interesting actually is
that
um I probably went on the job market a
little bit earlier than I should have my
main paper wasn't out yet and uh my
husband and I had a two-body situation
and you know they uh
you know you know basically we had in
the end offers on opposite coasts and it
was a bit problematic because we already
had a small child
um so we ended up taking a position at
Brandeis University together and we
started out sharing a position so we had
half a tenure track faculty position
each uh when we started so it was a
little bit of an unusual situation in
many ways right right now can we drill
down on that a little bit further
um mainly because it is the case that in
academic life you know uh uh Partners uh
oftentimes have to make tough decisions
you mentioned having received offers on
two coasts so um what was the thinking
process behind settling on Brandeis and
how did
um if I may ask how did Brandeis come up
with this sort of shared position that
of course eventually split off so I was
running your own lab
yeah well
um Brandeis had made an offer to Sasha
Nelson my husband
um they were really interested in a
slice electrophysiologist and that's
what he was doing I was doing very
different things at that point and
um
I was a postdoc at Brandeis so I knew
the place pretty well
um and I had not applied for the
position at Brandeis in part because I
was a postdoc here so actually Sasha had
the great idea well why don't we
actually go to Brandeis and just
make the suggestion to them and see what
they say and it's sort of a testament to
brandeis's creativity and
Entrepreneurship that they looked at
this crazy idea and instead of saying oh
no absolutely not they were like hmm
maybe we could make this work so it was
extremely unusual I don't think anyone
else has ever done it I don't think
Brandeis has ever done it since
um and I saw like I would recommend
taking half a tender track position but
in our case
um you know it worked out I think we had
faith that Brandeis was operating in
good faith that they really wanted this
to turn into two positions so that um
uh reassured us that this was this was a
risky crazy idea but maybe it would work
and it turned out to be uh you know a
great thing for us a great thing for
Brandeis so yeah that's one of the
things that I think is so interesting
about the story as so so yes it's it's
Unique it's unusual as you mentioned
Brandeis probably hasn't duplicated the
um the the or hasn't made a practice of
it but what's interesting certainly for
um people involved in relationships
coming out of either or in out of grad
school or in a postdoc
knowing that they can be creative that
they can at least ask as as you said
Sasha said ask the question why not ask
the worst they can do is say no right
yeah and I think what was what was
really critical about this was
certainly at that time in history
um a lot of places still wouldn't hire
couples I mean not every place but it
was changing but there were still places
where that was considered problematic to
have two people in the same Department
who were married
um
and
um
so
I think the sort of flexibility around
um hiring was really much you know much
things were not as flexible at that
point in terms of hiring
um couples it's become I wouldn't say
every place accepts that this is you
know if they really want to recruit good
people it's something they have to take
into account but certainly much more
common now
so
yeah so it was a creative solution I
mean I think
um
the best solution of course is that
Places come up within an extra position
not not half a position oh but what I
wanted to say was the critical thing
about how we structured it was a lot of
places would at that point in time you
know would make an offer to usually the
man and the woman would have a um an
adjunct position that wasn't on the
tender track with the idea that maybe
they could come up with a tender track
position down the road and that's not
the way this was structured it was
structured as we each had half of the
FTE right so um so that meant we were on
equal footing and it meant that you know
it was sort of an absurd situation that
couldn't last for very long but it meant
we kind of came in without an imbalance
to begin with so there were things about
it that were really very creative and
very kind of an attempt to be um
you know
um
uh sort of
Progressive about it and yet um you know
it was also problematic because we were
sharing one lab space one salary
um we also had
we're sharing our teaching
responsibilities which had its upsides
and downsides so you know it was a it
was an interesting couple of years for
starting out the lab so it lasted about
a couple of years before they split the
I think you know I'd have to go back and
check exactly it lasted about a year and
a half and at that point I got a k99 oh
sorry not a k99 to KO one of the K
grants I forget what it was
um that basically paid my full salary
how nice and that was enough for the
chair of our department to go to the
university and say hey look you know
it's not going to cost you anything
until after they would get tenure anyway
so why don't we just make it two
positions in the University
um converted it so it wasn't very long
yeah you know so it ended up being a
great
overall
um creative
approach that that resulted in both of
us being at the same place with you know
with the tender track job but wasn't so
clear it was going to work out at the
beginning but it was it was worth the
risk um in in any case and certainly in
retrospect definitely worth the risk
because of how it turned out yeah well
congratulations in any case on coming up
with this really cool solution and and
working with an institution that was
open-minded enough uh to say hey this
this let's try it why not it can work
um okay so now I'm gonna back away from
uh um the the sort of the job uh
establishing the job to ask this
question so why science and and maybe
I'm not thinking about your
undergraduate institution the right way
but when I think of Reed College
gorgeous institution really
um High Caliber uh intellectual activity
but I I don't think specifically of
Neuroscience I think more of do just
broad-based liberal arts education so so
how why science
right right well um I I think I'm one of
those unusual kids that declared at age
nine that I was going to be a biologist
and then I actually became one so
at that point in my life I thought being
a Bible
being some kind of population biologist
or ecologist out doing field work you
know and working with animal populations
that was kind of my you know my dream
um so you know read
um read us an amazing place
and I think a lot of people who are
interested in science or especially
Neuroscience um have a very broad set of
interests right I mean we get into
Neuroscience because we're fascinated by
the brain right the brain is what makes
us
human lets us learn and understand try
to comprehend the universe it sort of
intersects all of these other
things that you know philosophy
literature I mean all of this stuff kind
of comes into it when you're thinking
about how the brain works and what it
does so in some ways it makes a lot of
sense I think that somebody interested
in lots of things
um
but primarily in science ends up working
in in Neuroscience it just speaks to so
many
um elements of you know of uh of human
existence right so um so I kind of went
in to read knowing I wanted to study
biology and it was a great place to be a
um an undergraduate in science in part
because you still were steeped in all of
the liberal arts stuff which I loved
um and then the other piece of it is
that everyone there does a does a thesis
so everybody does a full year of
research and
um you know if you're in the Sciences it
means you're working in a lab and you're
actually writing a a senior thesis
that's a research you know you're
writing up a research project so it's
pretty amazing preparation for graduate
school
um so uh so yeah so that's you know I
would say neuroscience
that wasn't at all thinking about
Neuroscience until I took my first
Neuroscience class and then it was sort
of like you know being struck by
lightning it was like oh my God this is
the thing that I need that I want to do
and just so a complete shift from
thinking about
um uh
broadly construed environmental concerns
non-human biology to whoa brain is it
yeah not of course the human brain
because I study rat and mouse Springs
but nonetheless yeah
and so so
is it the case then that neurobiology so
so for for someone because the
Neuroscience is this Big Field yes it's
it's oriented around you know all things
brain
um but it's this really enormous field
uh in terms of how you can go about
specializing and sub-specializing how
did you come to then
um neurobiology so you you were
interested in biology you took the
Neuroscience class and you just went aha
this is it like how do you remember how
that struck you like what the details
were that you were looking at yeah
pretty much I think it just seemed
incredibly fascinating and and then um
The Next Step was that I I started to do
um summer research so I spent a a friend
of mine had been working at a in a
neuroscience lab in Portland and so
um I ended up getting a job in that same
lab over the next summer
um and then that sort of set me up for
doing my senior research so um yeah and
then it was just pretty obvious to me as
soon as I started working in a
neuroscience lab that yeah
and then
there's brain plasticity so it's it's a
term that you know we hear on the news
or we might you know uh
read somewhere but you know most of us
who don't study the brain from the
standpoint of uh scientific
investigation I think plasticity wait
does that mean that you know the brain
moves around or that you know if you're
missing a part of the brain another part
of the brain can fill in in other words
like how should someone like me think
about the concept of brain plasticity
right well it's a really big umbrella
term and there's a lot of different
things that it encompasses
um you could think about
changes in the brain when brains develop
so you know if you've ever watched a
little kid figuring out I don't know if
you have children but you know I became
quite fascinated in development as soon
as I had kids because it was amazing
like watching
um the things that they couldn't do one
day and could do the next day through
trial and error and and just um brain
maturation so so that's a form of
plasticity meaning the brain is changing
during development and basically the
brain is interacting with the outside
world and
um getting feedback and that feedback is
being used to make brain circuits better
at what they're trying to do so the
circuits that control reaching
um you know the first time your kid
tries to reach and grasp something it's
not going to be able to do it and it
takes a lot of practice and and changes
in the brain to make the kid able to do
it so all of those changes are basically
affecting
um synaptic connectivity within their
brains and making those brain circuits
able to accomplish the job so it's like
this incredible process of of tuning
these circuits up and matching them to
the environment so that's one form of
plasticity that I personally am very
fascinated with and that we study a lot
and obviously this has implications for
all sorts of disorders where
um
that neurodevelopment doesn't go
according to plan and for whatever
reason and it also raises interesting
questions about what kind of experience
we need as a young mammal to actually
make our brains work properly so so am I
thinking about
circuitry and synaptic connections the
right way when I talk about my mental
experience of let's say trying to think
through an argument right so you know
I've got let's say a chain of reasons or
long division that sort of argument
right and I've got to get from one idea
to the next to the next to the next and
suppose that I get stuck like I don't
know how to you know divide uh 32 by
four something like that so I'm stuck am
I right to think that
that there's this electrical firing
of some sort of chemical that's kind of
reaching out but not quite grabbing the
next uh neuron I mean I I'm sure I'm
messing up a whole lot of language here
but that that's like one way that I
think about it and then you were
mentioning how
um if as as so so forget just thinking
but when we're interacting when a child
let's say is learning how to reach for
and successfully grab something on the
table as they're working out depth
perception is it is it also something
like what I've described where when
you're talking about circuitry and
synaptic connections are is it that the
brain's trying to connect up parts
of itself with other parts
yeah pretty much I mean look you've got
a whole bunch of neurons in your brain
you know 100 billion or something
um give or take you know no one's
exactly sure what the number is and all
of those neurons are connected to other
neurons and how many connections are
there well some neurons have maybe only
a few hundred some of them have hundreds
of thousands of connections so you have
this unbelievably complicated
interconnected Network and it's divided
into sub networks that control different
aspects of our Behavior but each of
those networks that wiring is very
complicated obviously
um
somehow you have to fine-tune that
connectivity to enable all of these
complex behaviors that we can do and
that's true you know it's easier to
think about in terms of a motor movement
um but similar things have to be true
when we think about our ability to
reason or to
um
sing a song or
um you know parse the complicated
um philosophical argument right
um it's using different parts of our
brain but it's the same sort of
principles that said we don't exactly
understand this process right that's why
neuroscientists like me are still in
business
yeah and you will and you will be
probably for some time yeah certainly
long class when I'm actively doing
science
well so so then okay so you there there
are you you've mentioned um in talking
about so when you talk about singing a
song I think oh memory you talk about
um you know reasoning our way through an
argument or or sort of unpacking a
complicated uh uh concept
um you
are probably using memory but you're
also using some some other feature or
features of the brain
um and then you also mention
um disorders so for example you've
you've published work on
um that's related to epilepsy uh and and
autism
I don't know which if any you you can
um help us understand
um in terms of this idea of circuitry
and then you've got this really uh
interesting concept of fine-tuning which
if I understand correctly you think of
or or you work on in terms of this sort
of in
um internal system it's a effectively a
closed system of of fine-tuning is that
right
well not not necessarily actually
um I think one way to view it is that so
so the other piece of this that we're
really interested in is how it is that
you can
um that these networks these highly
interconnected networks that are very
plastic where these connections can
change all the time how is it that
they maintain some sort of stable
function over time so you know you have
a sense of self that is
um very constant you know pretty much
you can sort of trace it back all the
way to when you were a little kid you've
had this continuous sense of self and
things you're interested in and
um so despite all of the change that
you've undergone there's a sort of core
um stability to to you know
essential things in your in your brain
essential brain functions that's one way
of thinking about this at a very high
level
um when you think about sort of the
nitty-gritty of the actual circuit
um it's really hard to do that it's
actually hard to take a circuit that is
really plastic where all the connections
can change all the time which you would
want to learn you know a new motor task
or something
um without that circuit
um sort of becoming
um dysfunctional and the reason is that
um
these circuits are composed of
excitatory and inhibitory elements and
they're highly interconnected so you
could think about a um
uh
feedback amplifier like imagine Jimi
Hendrix playing his guitar with the
feedback right okay that's this positive
feedback loop where
um you're getting uh you know that sort
of ramps up and the sound and it gets
out of control right if it if it gets
too intense well our brain circuits work
the same way these little amplifier
circuits so you have some neurons that
are excitatory connected to other
neurons that are excitatory and they
feed excitation back so you have these
feedback loops that can get completely
out of control right
so
um the way to fix that is to have
inhibition so some neurons can actually
turn down the excitability of other
neurons and what that means is in these
circuits you have to balance the
excitation and the inhibition pretty
carefully to make sure you don't end up
with this runaway feedback does that
make sense it does and I a number of of
um ideas come to mind but given given
your work on
um the relation between the
um amplifiers and the the you know
modulators or or Inhibitors
um is it the case that you're saying
something like this if we so let's say
we have someone with you know uh
a psychiatric condition depression
anxiety you know something that's fairly
common among a lot of a lot of people or
something less common
um but but still you know fairly
prevalent like epilepsy or or Autism are
we saying that part of the the search is
for
um
bringing to bear or introducing one of
those sort of modulating or inhibiting
um uh
circuits into an existing sort of
feedback loop where there's sort of this
sort of spiraling out
yeah that's kind of um this is one idea
for some of the things that could go
wrong in some neurological disorders
okay the idea is that normally you've
got so you've got this potential excited
to Runaway excitation right and then
you've got inhibition that can come in
and keep it in check and the question is
how do you get that balanced right
because if the circuit is not excitable
enough if you can't amplify signals then
your brain doesn't work properly you
can't detect sensory input you can't
process it properly
if that excitation is too high then you
have the opposite problem right you end
up with this sort of runaway excitation
which puts these circuits into a you
know kind of an epileptic State this
hyperactive State and then it doesn't
function properly either so what this
says so this brings in this concept of
homeostasis which is what we've worked
on a lot the I and that's basically the
idea that
um you you can build a self-tuning
mechanism that keeps that balance
properly set so if like excitation goes
too high it'll detect that and bring in
more inhibition to compensate
um and vice versa and there's a lot of
ways you could do that tuning but um uh
but that's the basic concept that's sort
of very key actually Central Concept in
physiology this idea that certain things
like our body temperature blood glucose
all these things are under very tight
um negative feedback control so that
they deviate from some set point you
know 98.6 pretty close right if our
temperature deviates all these
mechanisms kick in to bring it back so
the idea is that circuits in our brain
work the same way that they're they're
plastic rules that essentially
sense you know what state the brain is
in and then tune it back to that sort of
set point where it's working properly
and so the coral area of that is that in
some disorders possibly
um that homeostatic process is not
working properly and so the circuits end
up mistuned in some way now how big an
effect is this you know how much of some
of these disorders does this account for
it we really don't know the answer to
that what we know is that using some
um well what we know is that some for
instance uh genes that are very high
confidence genes that cause autism in
humans if you take those genes and you
mutate them or or get rid of them in
mice or rats then you see behaviors that
are sort of congruent with the idea that
you know you've recapitulated
um some phenotypes in the rat or Mouse
model
and what we see is there are defects in
these homeostatic mechanisms
and so you know what's the causal
relationship that's complicated it's
going to take a lot of work to get at
but it does raise a sort of interesting
Avenue for trying to figure out how you
might
um
try to reinstate these homeostatic
mechanisms and would that have
therapeutic value so that's certainly
one of the things a lab is interested in
it's a long way to go from work and rats
and money is to really finding things
that that are effective in humans that
um so so when you were talking about the
analog and the rest of our
physical systems right that I was
thinking well yeah of course that makes
perfectly good sense and but it wasn't
until you articulated it you know as you
did that it that it sort of crystallized
um and and what jumped out for me was I
was thinking of a
um I developed a um
Hashimoto's thyroiditis when I was quite
young and it it struck me over the years
that
um you know so so the the brain is
screaming out for more uh of a hormone
that my body isn't isn't producing and I
and I often wondered you know well so
okay endocrinologist why why aren't you
all sending me to some sort of
neuroscientist like a neurochemist or a
neurobiologist you know somebody who who
can try to help me understand what's
happening in the brain but also
um uh what the the corollary is for you
know other ways that my body is feeling
reflected in the brain so then so I was
thinking that but then I was wondering
so so given
um some of what you've
some of the focus of your research I was
wondering kind of
what other analogies do you use as a way
to think about what's going on in the
brain since you're do you're you're
basically
car you know mapping the territory that
that hasn't really been mapped before
right so this is all new and you you're
you're having to find ways to
conceptualize what it is that you're
that you're doing
um am I right to think that one reason
why you focus on sleep wake Cycles is
because you're trying to use sleep and
wake as I don't know if analogy is the
right term but as a as a a way of
getting at this uh homeostasis that you
mentioned before the homeostatic
mechanisms
yeah I would say our work on sleep and
wake is sort of um
kind of came
we we started it for a different reason
I mean part of it was because
let's see
um part of it was based on some
assumptions that turned out to be kind
of wrong like we we basically had this
idea that well okay if circus of the
brain have a kind of Activity Set Point
right and so they're homeostatically
regulating around that if excitation
goes too high turn down the gain and
vice versa well sleep and wake are such
dramatically different brain states that
we thought maybe it would be impossible
for a neuron or a circuit to have
um a set point that would stabilize it
across those different states so we
thought you know possibly these
mechanisms could be turned on or off
during sleep or wake or maybe
um
maybe the set point of a neuron might
actually shift during sleep or wake in
some way so the circuit might be set
um it might have a you know a modifiable
set point that would change as a
function of brain State
um so it turned out actually when we did
these sort of chronic recordings in in
uh rats where we basically let them run
around for days we just recorded the
activity in their brain when they were
doing just their normal stuff you know
but sleeping waking eating playing now
it turned out that for sort of these
normal sleep and wake States the overall
level of activity the average activity
of the circuits are actually pretty
similar
so that the the original motivation
turned out to be wrong but at the same
time we discovered this sort of
fascinating thing which was that
um
the direction of compensation depends
upon the sleep and wake state so it
turns out that so you can think about a
system right where the
um activity has fallen below the set
point or activity has gone above the set
point so it's sort of a bi-directional
system right it has homeostatic
mechanisms have to be bi-directional and
they don't really give you a stable
output right
um
and what we found is that the upward
compensation only happens when animals
are are actively awake and sort of
running around in the environment doing
stuff whereas the downward compensation
only happens when they're asleep and
this was really kind of crazy because at
the molecular level
there's a fair overlap between the
mechanisms that drive upward and
downward so we had thought of it as a
single switch you know like a thermostat
um single thermostat switch and it kind
of suggested
that's not right
um there's some sort of higher level
control over the mechanism so um yeah so
it's really quite fascinating I would
say
um
it suggests that one of the functions of
sleep and wake States is actually to
segregate different forms of plasticity
to to make sure they're not happening at
the same time and exactly why that would
be is a big really fascinating research
question that we don't really have a
great answer for at the moment
so as you're as you're talking about
um
this most recent finding or most
recently you're talking about this
finding I'm thinking uh a couple of
things one is the way that you
articulate what's very complicated
um certainly for a lay person right I
don't have the uh vocabulary I don't
have the sort of con the technical
Concepts to help me um make sense of
what you're saying but there's a there's
a level of understanding that you're
helping me achieve because of the way
that you're formulating the word you're
choosing the um the the metaphors or
analogies that you're using and it makes
me wonder how
you go about either initially forming
um a hypothesis as you did with the um
concepts related to sleep and wake
Cycles but then also how you go about
either
rethinking altogether or recalibrating
as you did when you said oh what we
thought was happening isn't quite what's
happening so how does that yeah you go
about thinking through this stuff yeah I
mean I think that's one of the most fun
things about science is when I mean it's
okay it's fun when you have a hypothesis
and you go in and test it and it's right
there have been a few of those amazing
moments where you're like oh it really
works that way but it's also
um
you know if you if you could figure it
all out just by sitting at your desk
right why do the experiment so it it
it's it's even more in some ways
um exciting when
you go in with an idea and it turns out
you're just wrong and you have to look
really carefully at the data and think
about you know what does this mean okay
so of course you have to worry about did
I do the experiment right all the right
controls all of that you know that's the
the boring reasons why things might
might you might have got things wrong
but once you've ruled that out
um
you know to me it's sort of I love that
moment where you realize you're standing
uh in a you know
you're looking into a new environment
and you you've never seen it before and
you don't know how it works and
um it's like I don't know it's
it's like being an Explorer on the you
know
um the first one to see some exciting
terrain you know it's it's kind of an
amazing feeling so it's also scary right
um and you know often for the the grad
student or postdoc because of course I'm
not doing the experiments myself anymore
my I got this amazing crew of people
creative wonderful people who are doing
the experiments and you know it can
especially be difficult when their
cherished idea turns out to be wrong
um but uh but I do think these are the
moments that where we learn the most
right so
um it does
I think
um you know I tend my research tends to
be pretty idea driven I mean I do we do
like to just
go and look and see what we see but but
we we're usually going in with with some
road map that arises out of some
theoretical construct for how we think
it'll work and that's really useful like
it helps you design your experiments
properly you know it helps you come up
with the right experiment when you know
you're trying to really differentiate
between these two possibilities right
but it's also very easy to get sort of
fall in love with your ideas
um and cherish them too much and be it
can be very hard to abandon what is a
very beautiful idea when it turns out
that that idea
doesn't really describe what you're
seeing so it does take a certain
um I don't know fortitude to be able to
um
remain flexible in that way but you know
but that's that's sort of the Hallmark
of I mean that's when science makes
progress right it's a it's am I am I
overstepping when I say it's basically
the concept of plasticity writ large and
the discipline where you know you try
something out and and if it works great
you can stick with it
um and then if it doesn't work well now
you've got to try to make a new a new
connection
um yeah no I think that's absolutely
right and that's you know often we're
stuck as scientists we we have these
pieces of data and it's pretty clear
that our theory about how it all fit
together is wrong but we we don't know I
mean we don't have enough information to
know how it goes next and so like how do
you keep
um your mind open to these different
possibilities it could be a really
tenuous state to be in while you're
figuring out the right next steps and
where to go next but so I so I do think
there's a lot of uh yeah it requires um
a lot of flexibility of plasticity what
do you do to
like so what's your go-to you mentioned
that you know your work is presently
very idea driven like what what are your
go-to
um
resources uh what are your go-to tools
to think about where you might go with
an idea that you've you've been
sort of percolating kind of how does
that work for where do you do it like
like how does all of this uh come
together for you
right yeah I think this is a fascinating
question
um
you know that generalizes across I mean
this is just a question about human
creativity where does it come from yeah
yeah yeah and um yeah answer whether
it's in the Sciences or you know any
anything we do right
um I think science is interesting
because
at the same time you have to know a lot
and you have to you have to do a lot of
work to get to the point where you can
have a good idea right so you have to
read the literature you have to know
what people have done you have to
um
really understand things at a very
nitty-gritty level
um so you have all this detail you know
that you have to somehow
um
take into your brain but that's just not
enough right that doesn't ideas don't
you can't then sit there and sort of
logistically hammer out well therefore
it must be this way at least that
doesn't work for me so you know you
bring in all this stuff into your brain
and then it kind of rattles around in
there for a while and then something
happens and you know I can't explain
what that is I often I've had actually
graduate students you know when I go to
visit universities you have lunch with
graduate students and um and post-docs
and it's really a wonderful practice
they get to ask you all sorts of
questions and but a lot of times they'll
ask you know where do your ideas come
from you know how did you have this idea
or this idea and I I can't tell them I
mean
um
obviously most ideas have all sorts of
Precedence in the in literature people
have thought of similar ideas you know
so of course what your brain is doing is
taking these pieces that you brought in
and it's rearranging them and coming up
with something that is
um based upon all of this other stuff
but it's a new
variant right no I don't know how that
works I mean the only thing I can say is
that it works best for me when I'm not
in the lab so it's usually yeah you know
out on the hike or something like that
right when my brain is kind of
free-floating
um is when I have most of my ideas so I
I tell this to people in my lab you know
look you've got to work hard you got to
do all these things but you also you
need the downtime because that's really
when a lot of the creative stuff happens
at least for me I think everyone's
probably really different that way but
right I mean some people might do just
what you've said doesn't work for you
namely sort of
um you know really hammer out as you say
sort of the the implications of a set of
ideas
um you know and then and then some
people will do as you say you do which
is disconnect yourself from from the lab
and from sort of doing science and
you're just being a human in the world
um engaged in various activities that
somehow maybe give you time to digest or
percolate but also maybe give you
um new ways of thinking about the the
stuff that's percolating
um and I think it's really helpful for
people to know that they're you know
they they have to find what is going to
work for for their
sort of temperament or their sort of
intellectual disposition or whatever it
is that that that gets them that sort of
characterizes them being in the world so
thank you for sharing that but
um uh two final questions uh one is
given how young uh Neuroscience is as a
you know as a discipline in its own
right
um kind of how how
how do you keep up with stuff going on
around the world that's relevant to what
your work is on the assumption that
that's happening
um and then secondly
what do you want to see happen like
within the next 10 years
right well for the for to the first
um
actually
covet was a really interesting
um experience to go through because
most of us were scientists and I mean
people in general but we were sort of
cut off from our usual modes of
interacting which is we travel places we
meet other scientists face to face we
have conversations about what we're
doing they tell us about their work we
tell them about our work there's this
kind of talk about sparking creativity
it's like those personal interactions
somehow
are just way better than what we were
getting over Zoom so that's that's the
way we usually do it right and actually
the last couple of months I've been
traveling again and of course being
mindful of carbon footprint and all that
you know there's great things about you
know so it's it's complicated but um
but
obviously we can read the literature and
we can do all of those things we have to
do them to keep up with stuff but there
are you know thousands and thousands of
papers I mean there's something like no
30 000 papers a year on plasticity I
don't know I made that a number of but
there's a lot so we just can't keep up
with all of that
um so you have to be selective somehow
and then
it turns out that that's just not a very
humans are just not good at absorbing
information that way I mean we can it
can be very efficient sometimes but in
terms of like
paying attention to things and having it
spark new ideas it's really quite a bit
better to be interacting with people
um live you know so scientific meetings
are really an important way that
scientists
um interact with each other and get new
ideas you know you're learning about
stuff that's happening
long before it ever gets published so of
course it's much more on The Cutting
Edge but but it's also something about
the face-to-face interactions that I
find at least really make it
um much more effective so that's a real
dilemma I think as we're going forward
we're thinking about accessibility we're
thinking about being responsible
citizens you know it's
um it's hard for us I think like for
many
for many people to figure out how to
balance those
and then I forgot what your second
question is
um if if you could so I'll reformulate
reformulate it slightly
um
if you could have one question answered
within the next 10 years in your field
what would it be
oh my God I know it's horrible
what is consciousness
[Laughter]
that's too hard that's just too hard I I
guess
um I feel so it's one reason it's hard
is that
I don't think
um I think the way we're gonna
understand the brain is
slowly and sort of um holistically like
we're not gonna understand one piece of
it and then not the rest of it because
the problems are all the same problems
right okay so I think the field is going
to keep progressing but in a way that is
um
I mean we're really groping towards
trying to understand something as
complicated as the brain is
and so uh
you know I guess
if there was one thing I would let's say
I would love to have figured out maybe
by the time
um
you know by the time I retire I guess it
would be
um well it'd be really cool to
understand say
um what the mechanism is by which sleep
can switch homeostatic plasticity on and
off and control the direction
um that would be really pretty cool to
understand and I would really love to
understand how
these processes that we've been studying
for a long time how they actually enable
our brains to
um
to store
lots of information so you know we think
these homeostatic mechanisms probably
increase the capacity of of networks or
memory storage that's sort of good
theoretical reasons to think that based
on a lot of other people's Theory
um Theory work so it'd be great if we
could figure out why that is so those
are sort of two threads that are going
on in the lab now that are pretty
exciting
um but overall these are like tiny that
they're sort of big but they're also
sort of tiny problems that I think
that's where everyone's at right now in
Brain Research like we we hopefully are
going to start to get a handle on some
of these very fundamental processes
once we do that then I think we can
start to tackle some of the bigger
questions
oh lovely well I I hope that within the
next 10 years I'll be reading about your
answers to to both of those questions
and we'll be able to as you say move on
to um larger and larger questions uh but
in the meantime thank you so much I
appreciate your time and expertise
um and I know everyone is going to be
um very feel very lucky and be very
lucky to uh have heard from you directly
so thank you Dr Gina triggiano for your
time and
um we I hope that we will get to talk to
you again someday